اكثر من 150 علامه تجاريه تحت مظله واحده
في معرض العطور الذي انطلقت النفعاليات
موسم الرياض ليستمر حتى التاسع من يناير
ليضم اكبر تجمع للعطور والشركات المتخصصه
تبارك الرحمن
وانا اتوقع الحين على دجله الويكند وبدايه
اسبوع
المنتجاتنا موجود خصومات ان شاء الله
موجوده ونتشرف نلتقي بزباين السعودي
الذي اكتسبهم معرض العطور هذا العام كان
مختلفه
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والمشاهير
كانوا حلقه الوصل بين المعرض والجمهور
الذين جاءوا للسعوديه للاستمتاع باجواء
الموسم وزياره المعرض عدد من السوشيال
وصارون في معرض العطور والصراحه احنا
تعملنا انا نقول ان هذا المعرض حلو او في
من كل البراندات ما شاء الله من كل دوله
يعني ما شاء الله هل مره واصل مره طاري كل
مكان كل حد يعني ما شاء الله قلنا معرض
العطور صراحه هنا عندكم ولا لا
تجربته التسوق الاستثنائيه في معرض العطور
كشفت للزوار عن خصومات وهدايا ومنتجات
جديده
لمعرض العطور هذا العام لتتكرر زيارته
اكثر من مره من الرياض شهد المتروك
بالعربيه